that's not how the force works so very
suddenly and very unexpectedly Phil Lord
and Chris Miller have departed the young
Han Solo movie that would be the young
Han Solo movie still in production the
directors have left because of the
classic creative differences and yeah
this is this is not a good sign now I do
actually tend to believe the line that
were being given that it is creative
differences because there was word that
came out a week me maybe a little more
on time is lost so many for me lately
but it was weird not long ago that that
the studio that Disney was not happy
with what Lord Miller had put together
thus far they exactly what the issue was
seems to be something that's a little
less clear but it was worth that it was
too jokey or something but like there
was basically word that the reshoots
were going to have to be extended
because they weren't overly pleased with
what they saw now to be fair that also
appears to have been the kids with world
1 ultimately we got to bring the movie
out of rogue one so maybe there's
something so coverable but the director
didn't bail on road one so given the
instincts that Lord Miller tend to have
as a creative team I am NOT I I I don't
want to say I'm not shocked I am sorry
by what happened but I believe the
creative differences line I believe that
their vision for this film is not what
was ultimately wanted by Disney as a
studio so when when they realize that
they aren't going to be able to meet in
the middle the left now there has not
been a new director assigned yet and
there needs to be because there are
reshoots that have to happen and this
movie's got to be salvaged now the
reason this is a really big deal even
though I believe the creative
differences line is generally if a movie
is going to be saved when the
she leaves because of creative
differences they need to have left
before camera started rolling so some
other examples were turned out okay for
the most part would be you know ant-man
edgar wright left before shooting
started basically because of creative
differences he wanted more control than
they were going to give him and he left
so and there was a director on Wonder
Woman prior to Patty Jenkins who had a
different vision for the film and she
left and at this point you know they had
enough time to work with patty Jenkins
on something else that there's
effectively no traits from that other
director left and that's fine but in
this case there is a finished movie shot
now there were reshoots that were only
going to be reshoots but it's really
hard to completely reconfigure a movie
in reaches this is something that
justice is going to be contending with
later this year but here it's the case
of not I mean at least in justice league
the director left because of something
completely unrelated and by everything
that Joss Whedon has said he's coming in
to do his best to finish the movie as
Zack Snyder wanted to make it he's not
as far as we know actively trying to
reconfigure and rejigger it into a new
movie in the editing room which is what
it sounds like they're going to have to
do with this Han Solo thing and this is
just oh boy I end up for me especially
guys I've gone on record repeatedly up
to this point that really kind of the
only reason I was interested in this
movie at all was because of Lord
Miller's involvement not that I think
that they're infallible or like the
pinnacle of filmmaking or anything but
their whole career has basically been a
long list of taking bad ideas and making
good movies out of them 21 Jump Street
was a stupid idea they made a good movie
the lego movie was a ridiculous idea
they made an awesome movie 22 Jump
Street coming back and doing that again
they still made a good movie like this
is their entire mo so their involvement
gave me some hope so then leaving
removes a lot of that hope and also
creates a circumstance that it's just
going to be really really difficult to
recover from
I'm not sure what else there is to say
about this without rehashing a lot of
the stuff that I said when bringing the
last time I talked about Justice League
and what that's going to have to go
through back when I talked about how it
says of the Rishi's who are and that was
even before that setter and left that I
did that video but it is kind of we're
kind of looking at the same thing here
which is that you take a movie when you
try and reconfigure it in reshoots and
in the Edit and try and make it
something different oh boy like best
case and I think Road one's kind of your
best case scenario because and I like
rogue one a lot but you can feel how
stuttery and how jagged and how not
completely uniform it is as a product
particularly in the early half of the
film so you can feel the weight of those
expensive reissues on it and that may at
least retain the director so there was a
there was a continuous single person's
vision here they the people behind it
are gone they're walking away so
somebody else who is going to be
instructed not to complete the film as
envisioned by the original directors but
was not on it before so it's not going
to be able to craft it totally as their
own thing is guys to come in and just
take these pieces and make something out
of it and they'll get some ability to
make new stuff and create a new thing
but this oh and as of right now at least
Disney is not moving the release date
it's still talking about coming out I
think in March of next year yeah I might
have the date wrong but they're not
moving it off to release date as yet I
figure what if this thing is going to
have any hope at all it's going to
depend on who they get in to pick it up
I don't know who they could get in I
don't know who's willing to work on that
tight of schedule on basically out of
persons movie so there's that and I
think that they're going to have to move
this release date and I really hope that
they do because I movies get crippled so
badly by going we will release on this
date like look if it's not working take
the time to fix it so I hope and expect
that that release date will be moved
that and that the reason they're not
announcing it
just because they don't know when
they're going to move it to and they
don't just want to nebulously remove it
off the schedule they won't give they
won't tell us it's moving until they
know what date is move - that's my hole
at any rate um I'm not I'm as stunned as
I am that this is happening and I'm
going to keep an eye on it more on a
morbid curiosity than anything else
because I mean the young console wasn't
really something I had a ton of
investment in so I'm not I'm not
heartbroken over this because it's not a
prod it's a project that I get morbidly
curious it's kind of determined not
something I really had a lot of
excitement for and I think if anything
I'm more concerned that if if it results
in a bad product that doesn't do well
I'm more worried about what that means
for the future of these sort of side
Star Wars movies because as much as
rogue one again I like the finished
movie and it did pretty well that was
still a rough production so if that was
so rough and this one is rough if this
one also doesn't make a ton of money
Disney might just make the call these
things are too much trouble and they
might just continue sort of the side you
know the non main numbered Star Wars
movies and that I think would be a
bummer while I don't think everything
that they could do would be gold
I was enticed by the possibilities of
different story set in the Star Wars
universe things with different fields I
was looking forward to you know the fans
keep clamoring for an obi-wan movie and
if they set it on Tatooine sort of
between Revenge of the Sith and I new
hope you could get something that you
know feels like a Western or a samurai
story look and you know getting
different things different fields and
you know there's been talk of a boba
fett movie which could be your we're
kind of assassin sort of hitman thing or
has a good feel like the professional
dependent if they wanted to go that kind
of direction with it and I was excited
by the possibility of this universe in
this aesthetic being lent to different
types of stories in different genres and
I think coming out of this I'm not broke
up about Han Solo when we specifically
but I am concerned that if they
the whole thing goes out that they're
going to pull the plug on these kinds of
experiments and explorations to the
margins of Star Wars and that I think
could be a bummer but yeah this came out
of nowhere so what is your thoughts on
this particular turn of events whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it that we're
get to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter accounts little geek skin
listening to the council of geeks
podcast available on iTunes and stitcher
there is not going to be a new episode
of go home Hollywood you're drunk this
week because of technical difficulties
and next week I'm on vacation so there
won't be one then either but there is
still new stuff coming on the council of
geeks podcast feed and I also 1/2 of the
punch like a girl podcast that is also
available on iTunes and stitcher so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]